next question today hey David aren't
Democrats just as responsible for Donald
Trump being President of the United
States as Republicans the answer is of
course it depends on what you mean by
responsible so first and foremost just
as responsible our Democrats just as
responsible for Donald Trump as our
Republicans the answer's no okay so at
the micro level if you look at the 2016
election the people that are directly
responsible for Donald Trump being
president are the people that voted for
him and also the people that didn't vote
at all right because when you have 50%
election turnout if you don't vote that
is a decision with consequences that you
have made so at the micro-level
know the people who voted for Trump and
the people who didn't vote at all are
responsible responsible for Trump being
president of the United States now is
there a way in which Democrats are part
of the problem which led to Trump being
president the answer is absolutely okay
I am NOT in this analysis throwing in
with those who say Hillary was as bad as
Trump I am NOT throwing in with those
who say it doesn't matter whether Trump
is president or not I'm not throwing in
with them at all but what I am here to
tell you is that number one the idea
that we live in a truly functioning
democracy in the United States is
absolute in total farce we have in the
United States a corporate aa cracy where
corporate power and maintaining the
status quo of Democrats and Republicans
who disagree about the minimum wage and
net neutrality and other really
important issues but by and large all
are complicit in maintaining this status
quo where corporations and their
lobbyists get more and more and more
powerful and the individual has less and
less bargaining power it is all part of
the problem and in general big picture
you are not going to have the support of
those who benefit from the status quo if
you want to change the status quo and
this is why when we talk about the big
meta issues like campaign finance reform
and some of those other
on which Democrats and Republicans they
might have different sounding rhetoric
but by and large none of them are doing
anything to change the system they are
all going to be opposing forces to
really the forming the system in a way
that will work better for the individual
so the people who voted for Trump are
the ones that we say you are
specifically responsible for Donald
Trump now being president but the fact
that we have had decade after decade of
corporate power building the neoliberal
centrist center-right status quo no real
challenges to both corporate power and
maintaining the campaign finance system
that we have it's all led us to a place
where Donald Trump shows up helped by
Russia I don't deny that for a second
and slowly but surely knocks out each of
the 16 or 17 other Republicans that were
running against him they are all part of
the problem and it is a much bigger
problem than Trump supporter so I want
to be I hope at I'm not riding the fence
because I'm trying to be really really
clear Democrats who voted for Hillary
aren't personally part of why Donald
Trump is president but everybody who has
participated and when I'm talking about
Democrats and Republicans I mean our
elected officials in maintaining the
system we have they are all responsible
for what we are now dealing with but
David it just makes me feel more
comfortable to say that it was James
commis fault or that it was Russia's
fault or that it was Jill Stein's fault
yeah why do I have to bear some
responsibility here
well you don't and that's the exact sort
of like ostrich baring their head in the
ground ideology or mentality that too
many people on the left and right are
participating in and I'm not doing the
left and right are the same left and the
right do it equally I that's not what I
do but what I am Telling You is that our
Democratic and Republican elected
officials are all part of the problem
that we're now dealing with